failed TV shows dead actors
controversial storylines no problem a
good TV show will always find a way to
thrive and one of your favorites may be
up for a reboot in early 2021 Viacom CBS
and Paramount rebranded their little
noticed streaming service CBS all access
as Paramount Plus at launch they
announced an ambitious slate of programs
in development one of the most
significant intellectual properties on
that list Frasier according to deadline
Kelsey Grammer will reprise his role as
Frasier Crane the snobby arrogant
serially dating Seattle radio
psychiatrist whom he portrayed from 1993
to 2004 on NBC's Frasier as well as a
decades worth of Cheers the Revival is a
co-production with grammar's own Granite
Productions the actor had been trying to
get a new Fraser off the ground for at
least two years time
is irrelevant here in the seventh circle
of hell grammar told New York TV station
NBC 4 that the first episode of the
Revival will address the death of
Frasier's father Martin crane since
actor John Mahoney died in 2018 no
longer a radio psychiatrist in Seattle
Frasier Crane will head back to Boston
the character's original home on Cheers
to take a job as a college professor
Bibi new Earth will be back as Frasier's
former wife Lilith sternin and their now
adult son Freddie will be portrayed by
new cast member Jack cutmore Scott Niles
and Daphne is now College age son David
will also appear as played by newcomer
Anders Keith however Niles and Daphne
will not Ally McBeal arrived on Fox in
1997 and instantly disrupted the whole
TV landscape it was an hour-length
comedy with elements of drama soap opera
and fantasy something that had never
really been done before Ally McBeal made
a star of callista Flockhart and won
seven Emmy Awards during its 5 season
run including one for outstanding comedy
series even the theme song Vonda
Shepard's search in my soul became a hit
single in 2018 Creator David E Kelly
said a reboot could happen he told The
Hollywood Reporter but I don't think it
should be done by me if it were going to
be done it really should be done by a
woman 20th television began developing
in Ally McBeal Revival miniseries in
March 2021 Flockhart will likely reprise
her titular role while Kelly as promised
will hand over creative duties to a
female showrunner instead serving as a
Consulting executive producer in August
2022 deadline announced an Ally McBeal a
Jason series is also in development at
ABC produced and written by Gray's
Anatomy and mix dish executive producer
Karen gist the new legal comedy will
Center on the daughter of Renee raddick
a district attorney portrayed in the
original series by Lisa Nicole Carson
debuting in 1987 Married with Children
helped establish Fox's edgy approach to
programming originally titled not the
cosbys Married with Children offered a
dark and cynical take on the Family's
sitcom
[Music]
I think they're gonna kill us trying to
talk here son cash strapped Chicago shoe
salesman Al Bundy hated his job how is
once promising life had turned out and
especially his wife and kids lazy Peggy
obnoxious bud and ditzy Kelly the
raunchy provocative sitcom helped
establish fox in the TV game and the
show produced original episodes right up
until 1997. over the years various
attempts have been made to bring the
bundies back to TV in 2014 a reboot
about Bud Bundy moving back into his
childhood home didn't make it past the
development stage then in 2022 deadline
reported that Sony Pictures Television
had begun work on an animated reboot of
the original series development had been
in the works for a year prior to the
announcement with all four Bundy actors
signing contracts agreeing to reprise
their roles while Christina Applegate's
recent Health announcements May
complicate matters the remarried cartoon
remains in the planning stages and if
ordered will likely air on Fox Hulu or
peacock
the 1970s police action drama Starsky
and Hutch was one of the Definitive TV
series of its era David Soul and Paul
Michael Glaser portrayed detective Ken
Hutch Hutchinson and detective Dave
Starsky respectively they were friends
and mismatched Partners who tried to
keep the Mean Streets of Bay City safe
mostly by rolling around in a classic
red Gran Torino in 2004 Ben Stiller and
Owen Wilson attempted to bring the title
back with a movie adaptation earning a
respectable 88 million dollars at the
domestic box office in February 2023 The
Hollywood Reporter announced that fox
had begun work on a new version of
Starsky and Hutch like its predecessors
the series will Center on a detective
Duo this time however both leading roles
will be portrayed by female actors in
The Revival best friends and police
partner Sasha Starsky and Nicole
Hutchinson live and work in an oddball
Locale called desert city fighting
crimes and busting bad guys while also
trying to figure out who framed their
dads the show's producers are set to
submit multi scripts to the network
before a final green light is given in
the 1980s beloved actor Andy Griffith
scored another long-running TV classic
with Matlock he enjoyed a nine-year run
as Ben Matlock a masterful expensive and
quintessentially Southern criminal
defense attorney who works to exonerate
his accused clients while a staff of
investigators track down the real
culprit Griffith starred in a total of
181 Matlock episodes but following the
star's death in 2012 it became clear
that any reboot would require a
difficult recasting nevertheless in 2023
CBS ordered a pilot for a new series
selecting Academy Award winner Kathy
Bates to take over as the crafty sweet
smiling 70-something lawyer her
character will be Madeleine Matlock who
emerges from retirement to join the
staff of a high-end firm David Del Rio
and Leah Lewis are set to play matlock's
Law Firm Associates Billy and Sarah
while Jason Ritter has signed on to play
the son of the law firm's Chief partner
the wholesome family comedy who's the
boss was a Smash Hit for ABC airing from
1984 to 1992 Tony Danza returned to TV
as Tony Miceli a former baseball player
and single father who takes the position
as the livid housekeeper for advertising
executive Angela Bauer you sent me a man
for a housekeeper oh don't be sexist a
man can do meaningless unproductive work
just as well as a woman in 2020 Sony
Pictures Television announced a
continuation of who's the boss with
original series stars Danza and Alyssa
Milano on board as stars and executive
producers set more than 30 years after
the end of the 1992 series The Revival
finds Tony retired from his job as a
housekeeper and Samantha a single mother
living in her childhood home the same
house in which much of who's The Boss
took place nearly two years later in
2022 The Hollywood Reporter revealed
that one day at a time reboot writers
Mike Royce and Brigitte Munoz Leibowitz
would pen scripts for the new show an
exclusive to Amazon's ad supporting
streaming service Freeview many
comedians have built sitcoms around
their lives and stand-up routines but
Everybody Hates Chris was a little
different the 2000 series was set in the
1980s and dramatized humorous
heartwarming events from the life of an
adolescent Chris Rock as portrayed by
Tyler James Williams the life of TV
Chris was humorously chaotic dealing as
he did with his wacky family and trying
to fit in at a school where he was one
of the few non-white students in the
middle of its mid-2000s run Everybody
Hates Chris was nominated for best
comedy or musical series at the Golden
Globes making it one of the few UPN
shows to ever receive major Awards
attention the title Everybody Hates
Chris was an obvious spoof on Everybody
Loves Raymond and the Revival will add
another level to that joke and
acknowledge that time has passed
entering production under the name
everybody still Hates Chris in August
2022 Paramount ordered the series an
animated reboot for its Paramount plus
streaming service with episodes set to
air on comedy Central as well only one
cast member has officially signed on and
it's a key one co-creator and narrator
Chris Rock who will provide voice-overs
for more stories inspired by his
childhood in Brooklyn
following his years with the Monty
Python comedy troupe John Cleese
co-created and starred in the British
sitcom Faulty Towers he betrayed basil
faulty the forever angry exasperated and
inept operator of a small rundown Motel
listen don't mention the War I mentioned
it once but I think I got away with it
all right while only 12 episodes ran
over four years in the late 1970s Faulty
Towers is considered by some as one of
the best sitcoms ever made ranking on
IMDB's list of top TV series twice
winning the bafta award for best
situation comedy and being named as the
best British sitcom of all time by the
readers of the radio times in 2009
Cleese said that he wasn't interested in
a Faulty Towers Revival telling the BBC
I think everyone would be excited if we
did it the problem is when you do
something that is generally accepted as
being very good a horrible problem
arises which is how do you top it the
expectation of what you will do is so
high Cleese presumably found a way
though because in 2023 he announced a
Faulty Towers Revival is imminent Cleese
and his daughter Camilla will write and
star in the new show which will depict
basil faulty and the character's
daughter running a small hotel writer
director producer Rob Reiner will help
make the series via his Castle Rock
production company airing at 12 a.m
weeknights on Comedy Central from 2013
to 2017 at midnight offered a plugged in
alternative to the broadcast Network's
late night talk shows presided over by
host Chris Hardwick at midnight mashed
improv into a game show format with
three comedians or actors getting points
for the jokes and funny material they
created while making fun of junkie
online culture like memes blog posts
Instagram photos and celebrity news in
immediate hit and Emmy winner at
midnight ended its run as the cultural
climate quickly shifted When Donald
Trump became president online chatter
became dominated by political talk in
2018 Hardwick told Insider we were not a
political show with the Late Late Show
with James Corden ending its run in
April 2023 CBS found its replacement in
a new iteration of at midnight according
to deadline producing a game show
instead of a talk show will save CBS 25
million dollars in annual production
costs Stephen Colbert is set to serve as
an executive producer while the
embattled Hardwick is not expected to be
involved with the reboot hosting
rapid-fire jokes tons of sight gags Sly
sci-fi references and a vast overarching
mythology Futurama revolves around the
day-to-day exploits of Planet Express an
Interstellar delivery company owned by
genius scientist Professor Farnsworth
the Planet Express Ship is crewed by
one-eyed mutant Lila robotic misanthrope
bender and dumb slacker Philip J fry who
was cryogenically frozen in 1999 and
woke up in the year 3000 despite the
pedigree of Creator Matt Groening The
Man Behind The Simpsons Futurama was
never a ratings Smash in fact it has
been canceled and revived multiple times
after Fox ended the initial run in 2003
a series of direct DVD movies followed
which Comedy Central edited into a
season of episodes after ordering an
additional two seasons Futurama was
given another ending in 2013 and now
it's coming back again those asinine
morons who canceled us were themselves
fired for incompetence
in 2022 variety reported that Futurama
will return this time on the Hulu
streaming service original cast members
Katie Seagal Billy West Lauren Tom
philomar and others immediately signed
up to reprise their roles while John
DiMaggio the voice of Bender joined the
project following a pay dispute scripts
have been written the cast has performed
table reads and production has
officially begun with episodes to follow
in the near future in the last few years
Christopher Miller and Phil Lord have
become one of comedy's most prolific
writing directing producing teams they
directed The Jump Street movies co-wrote
and helmed The Lego Movie and produced
Spider-Man into the spider-verse which
won them the Academy Award for best
animated feature film before all this
back in 2002 Miller and Lord co-created
directed and voiced characters on Clone
High a silly animated sci-fi comedy
series for MTV that lasted only 13
episodes a parody of teen soaps of the
era Clone High takes place at a high
school populated entirely by the Clones
of historical figures created by a
shadowy Organization for devious ends
Clone High was quickly canceled but it's
become something of a cult hit in the
decades since particularly after the
Ascension of Miller and Lord to Comedy
greatness the pair signed up for a
Revival in 2020 and in late 2022 Miller
revealed on Twitter that the new Clone
High series will likely appear on HBO
Max sometime in 2023
[Music]